we begin this morning with tropical
storm Florence it is no longer a
hurricane but it is still a threat to
millions of people in the southeast and
parts of the mid-atlantic states this
morning while Florence's winds have
weakened since making landfall Friday
morning the storm is still expected to
drench the Carolinas for days causing
catastrophic floods and life-threatening
storm surges the eye of the storm has
moved south along the Carolina coastline
it's approaching the Myrtle Beach area
but bands of heavy rain have been
battering North Carolina overnight last
night flooding intensified near Raleigh
the capital a creek ran over its banks
it's water running up against the back
of a nursing home the residents were
forced to evacuate so far Florence is
blamed for at least five deaths more
than 25,000 people in North Carolina
South Carolina and Virginia are in
shelters just over 1 million customers
are without power CBS Evening News
anchor Jeff Glor is in Wilmington North
Carolina Jeff good morning Dana good
morning to you we remain under a flash
flood watch this morning that will
continue for days here we're looking
right now at sustained gusts in the 30s
up to 39 with potential gusts at times
occasional gusts up to 50 right now the
issue here again remains the timing and
the duration of this storm is move so
slowly a three miles an hour for a time
yesterday as it churned along North
Carolina now into South Carolina it's
moving about five miles an hour right
now but that is bringing so much rain
we're talking about up to nine point six
trillion gallons of rain before Florence
is done here in North Carolina
Florence's cruelty brought a group of
firefighters to their knees as they
mourn the deaths of a mother and her
infant daughter weight that came down
after a tree collapsed on the family's
house first responders were able to
rescue the baby's father who was taken
to a nearby hospital early this morning
a man in North Raleigh walked away
unhurt after being trapped in his
bedroom by a downed tree Florence first
made landfall early Friday sheets of
rain
pummeled Wilmington its wind blew right
through stop signs so far about 500
people have been rescued in North
Carolina a swift boat search for the
stranded in Newbern while a rescue boat
went on the hunt for stray dogs in
Jacksonville more than a million people
in the Carolinas have been left without
power that number could reach 3 million
by the time the storm is over where's
your house it's can't really see it you
see that tree up there that's falling
yeah
that's us
go on to the right there when people
return to their homes to assess the
damage not everyone will be as lucky
there's this woman content just miss the
window makes you believe in angels so
need to replace the gutter I can live
with that all day long that was amazing
that tree at George paces how it's
basically split the uprights it went in
between two large homes that is not the
case in many other spots there are so
many home are trees down in this
historic neighborhood it's going to take
days if not weeks to get all the power
back here